[Music]
oscar-winner Jennifer Lawrence also at
the L women in Hollywood Awards told the
audience she felt humiliated when she
was younger and producers on a film told
her to lose 15 pounds in two weeks why
do I before me and already during this
time a female producer having to a nude
lineup with five women who are much much
better than me we all stood side by side
with homie paced ons covering our
privates and jll says that embarrassing
moment wasn't the worst of it
after that degrading and humiliating
line up the female producer told me I
should use the naked photos of myself as
inspiration for my diet oh my god last
night Jennifer told us she's committed
to creating change we're creating a
community you know where we're coming
together and we're creating a community
of support thank you to my strong and
awesome girlfriends who have supported
and loved me and celebrated my success
we will change this narrative and make a
difference for all of those individuals
pursuing their dreams
[Music]
you